hey kelly what's up nothing
oh except oh my god jim last night ryan
and i
totally finally hooked up it was awesome
that's great
i'm really happy for her i know it was
so funny because we were at this bar
with his friend and i was sitting next
to him the whole night
and he wasn't making a move so in my
head i was like ryan what's taking you
so long
and then he kissed me and i didn't know
what to say so i said
ryan what took you so long and you just
said it to him can you believe that
wow oh my god jim is that embarrassing
i'm embarrassed
no don't be no thank god because i was
nervous jim you will not
believe i was so nervous but now now i
have a boyfriend
i hooked up with her on february 13th
i don't know what he's thinking but i
would just be so psyched if we just
dated forever
no i take it slow because it seems like
a lot of the time things like that need
soda cool
hey so do you want to do something
tonight or oh no not while i'm
here i mean i know that's valentine's
day or whatever but there's totally no
pressure at all
of any kind whatsoever so i can't
tonight i have plans with my friends
okay um that's cool okay completely
understand
cool okay
oh uh i'm actually not a waiter this is
my plate oh my god
that is mortifying i'm sorry you just
had so many
there's two different kinds way more
embarrassing i told you that something
like this would happen one day
of course i'm jamie we didn't eat before
we came so that's why
i'm lucy and can you please offer her
one of these since you have about a
million of them
i got one yeah so how do you know colin
i was a resident with him
what do you two do well jamie is a latin
professor at nyu and lucy is an
assistant district attorney
that's incredible dark and stormy yeah i
love one thanks
sit down so you teach latin huh yeah is
that a popular class
ah not as popular as it was like two or
three thousand years ago
back then even the dumb kids spoke a lot
and it was a great time to be a latin
teacher i guess it's hard to sell kids
on learning a dead language oh we don't
like to use the term debt
we try to go with pointless or waste of
time
useless may i make a marketing
suggestion i would love it we need it
you need to get them to make another
indiana jones movie those movies make
latin look so
cool he's in a cave he's reading a latin
inscription by torch
you know the latin department doesn't
have as much sway in hollywood i think
you're maybe thinking of the hebrew
department
and that's offensive by the way yeah
it's very edgy yeah a little bit
so then the next movie moves to the top
of the queue so number five becomes
number four number six becomes number
five number three becomes number two etc
etc and let's just say that i just sent
back love actually which was awesome
and they sent me uptown girls which is
also awesome but guess what
now i wanna see love actually again but
it's at the bottom of the queue oh no
what do i do
what i do is this i go online i go click
click click and i change the order of
the queue so i can see love actually as
soon as i want to
it's so easy ryan do you really not know
how netflix works
i guess i forgot you're such a gift
kelly and i broke up and she can do
whatever she wants and her new boyfriend
seems awesome if you're into indian
people
i'm not
ravi makes me incredibly happy and ryan
puts me through so much drama
so i guess i just have to decide which
of those is more important to me
oh
[Music]
you are toxic you are toxic kelly okay i
have a few things to say to you
please don't interrupt i wasn't going to
interrupt maybe you do a lot so just
don't
thank you i know that i haven't always
treated you the way that
you for whatever reason feel you deserve
to be treated
but i want to marry you kelly kapoor
maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but someday and probably barf
oh you suck what is your problem hey
hey hey can we turn this back around
quickly please can we turn this around
quickly this is
very important turn around turn around
thing around please thank you she don't
want to turn around thank you
kelly i can't promise you that we'll
always stay together
i can't promise you that i'll never
cheat on you nor should i modern
marriages aren't built that way
men aren't built that way there's a very
interesting article i can email to you
but i can tell you this even if the odds
are 50 50 that will break up within the
week
i want to roll those dice i love you
kelly
will you roll those dice with me you
mean so much to me
but i love ravi and i choose him no you
don't
i do i do i hope we can still be friends
i have a hug
oh yeah well it's good to see kelly's
been sharing
oh god
[Music]
see how they mindy oh god
sully jamie subway means hello in latin
i look that up online what are you doing
here i'm with students right now
i know that but on your website it says
that office hours are open to anyone why
are you
dressed like indiana jones indiana jones
i think you mean
indiana jones ow
god i just i whipped my ear is it can
you can you look is it bleeding
or is it just reddish did any of you
guys have any like neosporin
professor should i call campus security
not yet ashley let's see how this plays
out
i'm sorry you find me a threat what
would you even tell them
there's a sexy indian woman with a whip
and a hat he'd be like yeah that sounds
like paradise
with all due respect think that ashley
has a little bit of a crush on someone
jamie can i yeah one second i'm so sorry
okay just i think i got a little
insecure about like the whole lucy
thing well it wouldn't be the first time
that that kind of weirded out
a potential relationship i want you to
give me another shot because
what do you say yeah of course
so how are you awesome
i am dating a lot of guys good a lot
black guys mostly kelly what
i want you to tell me that you care
about me that is what i want
kelly i'm your boss now okay you can't
keep talking to me like i'm your
boyfriend
oh big strong man fancy new whatever i
don't think you ever cared about me i
never cared about you
six months ago karen filippelli sent me
an email asked me out i said no because
i was committed to our relationship
well i hope you're still committed
because i'm pregnant
and guess what buddy i am keeping it
okay
okay do you feel prepared to help me
raise a baby
i can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner
we'll talk about it then okay
we have a date i don't understand why
our website needs to have social
networking at all yeah i actually have
to agree with dwight on that one it's
all about creating a one-stop
consumer experience all right you're
chatting with your friends
you're talking about the latest music
about the election all of it is
happening
in our virtual paper store and then an
older gentleman asks you boxers or
briefs
i don't get the big fuss here i like the
site if i had created a website with
this many problems i'd kill myself
do you have a question kelly yeah i have
a lot of questions number one how dare
you
wait wait jamie um before we go into the
most romantic building on the entire
planet
can you just tell me one thing yeah just
you're not in love with
lucy are you why do you keep saying
things like that
it just seems like you were really
jealous of her and danny at dinner okay
i'm not jealous of a guy who wears
boot-cut jeans all right see that sounds
jealous lucy is my best friend
next and if i love her it's the way i
would love a sister um i have a brother
and if
she looked at me that way i would have
to talk to our dad next
next let's go lady okay we're trying to
sort something out right now all right
can you just give me a break here just
look into your lover's eyes it's
valentine's day for god's sake
come on quick scenario okay you are on
death row because you murdered a cop
what this hypothetical you could only
see one more person before they
electrocute you who would it be my
lawyer because i wouldn't do something
like that okay your lawyer bungled the
case and you have one person to see
before you die
you can say me if it's me
it's lucy
i knew that you're good at this it's
lucy
i'm in love with lucy
traumatizing it's okay it's not it's
it's just i'm okay with it
okay folks next come on let's go
i'm a man in love
this has not been a good day for you
okay all right
oh look at this mud can you imagine if
i'd won my jimmy choos
i just saved you 600 bucks mister thanks
for helping out see
kelly you're here hey ryan
hey whose baby is this oh are you like a
manny now
no this little guy is mine
so i was dating this girl and one day
she went out to get a new charger for
her e-cigarette
never came back hold the story in the
book
say hi drake drake is your baby's name
yeah
that is an amazing name i'm obsessed
with drake his last album
it just touched me no kelly he's not
named after a hip-hop artist from 2011
it's drake like a mix
of drew and blake
well he is so cute robbie check out this
cute baby
i'm obsessed with him ravi is a
pediatrician and some of his patients
are total uggos
uh they're called premature sweetie yeah
no it's good to see you again right
ravi ravi
drake has a bit of a rash and he's hot
i know i was wondering could you maybe
examine him for a second oh yeah you're
not feeling well little guy
okay sure um should we go inside
actually could you go inside i'm feeling
a little
dehydrated i could really use a little
break have some water are you sure you
don't want to go in
ravi just do it that baby is burning up
isn't this like what you live for
just come go thank you ravi thank you so
much this is great for me after drake
thank you
[Music]
i don't know ryan maybe drake didn't
look so good he'll be fine
i let him suck on a strawberry he's
allergic but i'll get over it fast i had
to talk to you
you gave your baby an allergic reaction
just to talk to me
i love you i love you too we're gonna be
together forever we're running off into
the sunset
finally master commitment
you